yeah because how okay so since leaving
Rock Nation
how many projects have you dropped with
Empire because it's been
two and a half three years now
I've been two years exactly well two
years in a month exactly you know in
that time how many projects
um I think we had like 15 or something
like that Jesus so the multi-million
dollar deal is for those 15. nah it's
just for uh or for your 2021. it was
just for the 2021
catalog so all the [__] I did in 2021
did you turn it down
um yeah yeah
respectfully you know and then you know
if it's the opportunity is still there
we'll Circle back around but are you
like you could be like yeah [__] 2021
take that take the bread and then you
know just run it up in 2022 in 2023 and
not for sure for sure it's a um
is like a a great feeling to know that
that's there and also like it got me
looking at the board a little bit
different and setting goals a little bit
different because it's like like I said
I haven't spent any money on marketing
right so I got money let me invest some
money in marketing and some of this old
[__] because it's really not that old
people got songs that's three years old
to [__] around and go viral and catch
for sure it's been happening all the
time yeah so let me put a um now it's
like let me put some effort into
marketing this old [__] while I'm still
dropping some new [__] because I feel
like I I haven't maxed out the situation
it's like if I could get that then you
know why not try to get [__] 15 20
million
um do you feel like you could ever
do the major label thing because you've
been so like I feel like you've been
thriving on being under empire being in
a situation where you call your shots
you could drop it anytime you want yeah
uh the major the major thing isn't for
me just how just the type of person that
I am and how I grew up like bro I got
like a serious problem with authority
you know what I mean and when you put
yourself in a major situation it worked
for every it worked for different people
right so everybody thing is different
but for me specifically I hate having to
go
explain why my record is tight and why
it might work and why it's necessary
when it's clearly this is what I'm in
the building for for what I do you know
what I mean so I don't think the major
thing is my it's not my cup of tea at
all because even before I signed they
was giving me a hundred grand for a
project for each project and I was just
coming out you know I mean is because I
understand business and the hustle right
so I had
what I realized when I signed the Rock
Nation already had everything that a
label got besides radio I already had my
own digital marketing team I already had
my own PR right and then I got you know
I'm the Strategic partner so it's like I
pretty much got like the meat and bones
of what a label did because all I did
was sign and um
you know that's another story but yeah I
never I never signed to a major ever
pretty much they're just giving you an
advance at that point it's like I'm
signing for an advance and radio play
that never happened right and I'm in it
I'm not in it for the fame like I'm in
it because I like to make music but I
love to hustle and be able to do I love
to be active and I love challenges and
[__] so like I don't want to put myself
in another situation where the challenge
is me just getting music put out and
then if the [__] don't perform highly
expected then everybody moving on to the
[__] other hundred thousand artists
that's out [__] that
like I'm in it like crazy I was gonna
say like like you're obviously famous
right you're not like a a superstar but
like you know amongst the West Coast
hip-hop
world you are one of them ones you know
what I mean yes but pretty much any City
I hit somebody gonna notice me and [__]
right but I do feel like a lot of
artists they get into this [__] and they
focus on the wrong [__] which is like
being famous or oh man the look
academics ain't post me or all that type
of [__] and it's like I feel like you're
doing so much better than a lot of these
guys because you kind of are approaching
the game from a whole different
perspective like
you're putting your money in the right
[__] you're like using the music as a
vehicle to set up like long-term wealth
you know what I'm saying exactly I'm in
it for the long game because that's
where that's where the money is at in
the long game and I think a lot of
artists got like this Cinderella
idealism in a head which it also stemmed
from the streets think about it in the
streets I'm broke one day I [__] around
and hit a lick and then I'm up shining
the next day you know what I mean now
like business business don't work like
that you got to put in the footwork and
and really grind it out so a lot of
people do it to get that advanced and to
get [__] like this in this and then be
broke and then and then and get to
complaining about a situation that they
took so you signed it's like yo you
complaining but you signed the paperwork
right you know what I mean